hey guys my name is Michael chernow chef
and restaurateur and this is the
breakdown my background in the
restaurant industry goes deep I've
worked in restaurants my whole life
pretty much I've worked every single
position in a restaurant front of house
back at house there's really nothing I
have not done food hospitality is part
of my DNA today we will begin by
learning to boil eggs let's talk about
this for a second so I remember very
clearly first couple days in culinary
school now I went to the French Culinary
Institute and it was no joke school just
hearing that just like the lesson from
someone who's insanely passionate about
cooking that's French it's like burned
into your brain but you are not an
advanced cook but I do know how to boil
an egg so let's pause right here so this
is another thing that that sort of
happened over time so many people are
going to culinary school today and they
think that when they graduate culinary
school like their chef most people
actually I guarantee you I mean maybe
some of you guys know how to boil an egg
but if I said hey soft boil me an egg I
would argue that none of you would be
able to do boiling an egg properly is
definitely a skill set that you must
learn this is another great thing that I
think is SuperDuper important for people
to know if you don't sharpen your knives
regularly you run a much higher risk of
cutting yourself because you want your
knife to be able to go through something
very quickly and that's something that
they'll teach you in culinary school in
intensely there's also a bunch of people
that don't go to culinary school that
just work in the fields and learn the
hard way and most people in a kitchen
will actually wait for you to cut
yourself to like show you how to
properly sharpen your eyes it's not
important to cut an onion quickly when
you understand how to cut something and
typically even some of these guys here
are running it a little close like you
the blade of the knife to be running on
this part of your finger they're holding
it like this so if you hold it like this
and you're not really good boom you cut
you run the risk of just cutting the tip
of your finger off as the onion gets
smaller you need to hold it like this to
hold it in place but I typically cut
like this so like there's no chance of
me cutting the tips of my fingers I Bend
these fingers back but you want every
single piece to be exactly the same size
it's SuperDuper important especially in
a fine dining establishment are you dead
I think in culinary school if you had
that many onions on your station you get
assassinated they wouldn't allow for
that to happen if you have three onions
they're in a bowl
if you cut those onions in half those
haft onions are in a bowl the only thing
that's on your cutting board is the
onion that you're cutting and the pieces
that you've already cut everything is
like super organized
super clean I actually learned that
stuff at culinary school you know that's
the stuff that that really helps you to
be successful as as a cook or a chef
culinary school today is a little bit
different you know there's a lot more
people but I would say in terms of like
the demeanor of the chef's and the and
the teachers it's very similar there's
like no nonsense and this guy was very
polite with her chef's hat for sure
that's what the chef instructors wore at
culinary school that is accurate he's
wearing a lab coat most chefs coats are
double-breasted like the guy on the left
here that looks like a typical chef's
coat the guy his chef's coat looks like
maybe just a super old-school chef's
coat also just to be real you would
never ever be allowed to be in a kitchen
in culinary school without a hat on
that's like the biggest nono of all time
ever like you get a hair in your food
and it's just game over
all right next up cook up a storm whoo
so basically what that thing does is it
offers a little bit of sharpening but
ultimately it makes the blade super
straight when you're cutting things the
blade gets these little Nick's in them
and ultimately those Nick's become dull
and so what this is doing is it's just
sharpening the blade
filleting a fish is not easy a knife
that you use to fillet a big fish like
that it's very heavy the blade itself is
very very heavy so it can lay down on
the bones and actually cut through with
weight down on the bone so it doesn't
lift up so a super sharp heavy heavy
heavy knife it's typically what the
Japanese used for cutting knives for
filleting knives but when he's running
his finger across the the salmon he's
actually looking for pin bones and those
bones are a pain in the ass you see that
that bone that just popped up in
experience people that are working with
fish don't know that those bones exist
because they're not right there in front
of you they actually sit just below the
flesh but they're short like this long
and they're incredibly hard for the most
part all fish have them but in our
bigger fish they're hard and if some if
you don't pull those out big trouble
like bone in the gum trouble not good
and he's probably gonna pull out a
tweezer and start up there he goes Wow
look at that I don't know I've never
seen anybody pull pin bones out like
that they're actually pretty hard to
pull out and they don't just dip out
like that so maybe that guy's got some
serious superhuman talents you know I've
actually never seen a cross cutting
technique like that and done the way he
did it so it looks pretty incredible
though I gotta say like that is that
dude has got some swagger there's no
doubt I mean it's awesome
it's awesome let's fast-forward to the
kitchen
so he looks like he's working with some
why'd you be fair like you is incredibly
fatty marbled meat it originated in
Japan this why'd you beef technique they
massage the cows they feed the cows the
cows Guinness beer the cows are treated
literally like royalty and if you've
never had why'd you it's an experience
through the a walkathon y'all the
kudo-kai thermoform will 32 a d1 poodle
in a smelly Achieva so sous-vide is a
style of cooking we basically take a
piece of meat piece of chicken piece of
fish piece of beef piece of pork and you
put it in this plastic bag you drop it
in the cryovac it sort of seals it and
then you put the you put the protein
into this water bath you can cook it the
perfect temperature and it could cook
for 48 hours but it'll stay the same
temperature you get a similar sort of
texture with with any piece of protein
when you subete it that looks very very
good what creates fire typically when
there's hot oil and water it makes a big
boom similarly wine also will spark fire
alcohol makes fire rice wine vinegar
will create something like that
basically what they have here is what we
call cooking sweets they're very
expensive but they're it's typically a
huge oven or a huge of them with a big
range across and there there's typically
a number of different stations on top of
it in a fine dining establishment
there's a number of different components
that go into every single dish and
there's different cooks that are cooking
specific things for each dish so if you
have them all in one area and they're
all able to sort of communicate with
each other around this cooking sweet it
makes life a little bit easier
yes sir like what he just did there like
he cut that with a paring knife that
would never happen you would not use a
paring knife to cut a piece of meat
to plate you would definitely 100% use
your chef's knife everything else looked
legit until I spent all of that so now
he's doing a little smoking technique so
he's gonna put that on and he's gonna
blow smoke in there too to give that a
smoky flavor to give that dish a smoky
flavor cook up a storm
it's definitely exaggerated I mean it's
the the dramas there it's cool I'm into
it but you know they would never cut a
piece of beautiful meat like that with a
paring knife
all right guys are about to throw on
burnt
[Music]
okay so just off the bat this is intense
there's no doubt about it and like when
a restaurant of this stature is full
throttle Friday night
eight o'clock there's a hundred and
pointing covers in the dining room there
is a level of intensity for sure however
typically this looks a little chaotic
typically when you look into a kitchen
of that stature
it is completely organized so that feels
like an intense moment and there's
definitely intense moments but they
exaggerate this a bit the chef of the
restaurant will always you know walk
over and look over somebody's shoulder
and if you see something that's not
being done the way he wants it done he
will sometimes just push you out of the
way and take it over or tell you and
either a nice or not so nice way how to
do it the way he wants you to do it like
a chef like this is looking at every
single dish that's coming out of the
kitchen as a piece of art and they take
it that seriously and so you can imagine
the level of stress that that is on
chefs like that let's just say they do a
hundred to you know 102 cover 100 covers
a night when I say covers I mean people
100 people a night let's just say 100
people you know and and and it's a
fine-dining restaurant where there's
five or seven courses or whatever it is
that's 500 dishes coming out of the
restaurant a night every single one of
them needs to be precisely perfect and
if it's not it doesn't go out and if it
goes out and it gets sent back it's not
fun
[Music]
yes that right there is a moment that I
think is incredible right like that is
he he did that so well if a chef gives
you that moment right there where he
said look at me in the eyes and is not
gonna like annihilate you that is a chef
saying I like you I think you're awesome
I'm trying to mentor you this is this is
that that is a good thing that's a good
thing sweetie so that right there if
someone saw you do that in the kitchen
what she just did
nightmare trouble for you you have a
tasting spoon in a kitchen like that
always I mean that [ __ ] happens all the
time just to be honest with you like
that's the truth but I mean it's nasty
and so that's why you always have a
tasting spoon on you so if you're gonna
taste something you have a spoon that
you taste and then you throw it you know
you you you run it under some water and
you put it back in your pocket what's
your name again I mean next time you
make cuts you're toast the pepper first
remove the moisture and then you want to
grind it by hand yeah let's see that one
again so she just took her spoon tasted
and that put it right back in the dish
if I see that you know it doesn't go
over well so I think what's happening
here is he is her mentor and in the
world of restaurants once someone is
your mentor they're always your mentor
it's never like oh you've come up and
now you're doing your thing and you're
and you're everywhere and you're like on
my level it just that's just not the way
it goes my mentors guy a guy named Frank
frozen zombies he was my boss before I
opened up Seymour's and he still is my
mentor and he'll come into any one of my
restaurants and break my balls about
everything shows that co-ceo will clap
off
yeah yeah our trick sure the typical
chef has a massive ego and our very type
A that's classic
male-female doesn't matter there's very
few things that get that are as an
intimate as as preparing something
that's going into somebody's body when
you look at the role of a chef who's in
control of feeding hundreds of people a
day thousands of people a week it's a
very very serious responsibility right
like you're putting food in people's
people's bodies I mean we don't really
think about it that way on our regular
basis but it's true you know and it's
for real and so when you're trying to be
the best at that it comes with baggage
you should a sense it's inspectors to
restaurants to eat and award stars one
two three or none I'll just stop here
and say like the world of Michelin star
restaurants it is the top of the top at
the top the most elite and like there
are definitely restaurants today that
have Michelin stars that you're like
Michelin star that diner really but if
you have a Michelin star it is because
you actively have pursued one it doesn't
just happen the level of intensity that
one would have to endure to gun for a
Michelin star or two or three forget
anything else in your life if you're
going for three Michelin stars it is
because you live eat sleep in your
restaurant
all right guys we're gonna move on to
chef I've been waiting to talk to this
prick for a long time I am NOT cloying
I am NOT needy I don't care what you
think you're not getting to me
I'm not needy this is obviously a scene
where a food critic walks into Jon
Favreau's restaurant who's given him a
terrible review and now he's back for
food
and I think chef is approaching it you'd
have to be drunk really angry you know
prose super high-level reviewers that
are writing for The Times or something
like that
definitely know what they're talking
about but you know sometimes I'm like
you don't have to get you don't have to
do that you know
however today with Instagram and you
know like every single dish that comes
out of every single restaurant is
walking into a photo shoot that is this
the way it goes like today everybody's a
critic
it sucks everybody has different palates
and you know you just got to be prepared
for that
I've never seen anything quite like this
before like this is so dramatic I don't
think that it would necessarily happen
although I'm sure at some point it has
it wouldn't be good if a reviewer is
coming into your restaurant a super
high-level reviewer is coming into your
restaurant
it is because your restaurant is at a
standard that would warrant somebody to
walk in and review your restaurant and
typically a chef that's cooking at that
level does not want to have a
long-standing bad relationship with
restaurant reviewers so he probably or
she probably would not address someone
like that if they gave a [ __ ] about
their career long term I don't think a
chef would be going after a critic the
way he is going after a critic because
that's just like death by suicide you
know like you just don't go ahead on
with a critic before you deal with it it
sucks you take it and you pray to God
that they come back in so you can wow
the [ __ ] out of them and in your heart
of hearts you know that you can hate
that person but like you can't attack
them we're gonna fast forward a little
bit so now suddenly you're gonna be an
artist will be an artist on your own
time oh man this hits me like right in
the gut the restaurant business is such
a hard business man it's like you you
it's like this conversation that they're
having right now is so typical there's
so many different ways kitchens are run
if it's a chef owner
there's no shot that the pronounced
manager has precedence over a chef/owner
ideally and most in in most scenarios
the general manager and the chef of the
restaurant are in cahoots and they have
a great working relationship and so
though these fights happen but miss
conversation wouldn't happen between a
chef and a manager this would be a chef
and an owner next up one of my favorites
ratatouille so I mean obviously he does
not know what he's doing he's got a huge
stockpot sitting on his station that
would never be okay like you have bowls
set up for uncut vegetables cut
vegetables and and then peels like onion
peels or something like that so like you
have like your your trimmings your on
cuts and your cuts and you would never
have a stockpot sitting right on your
station like that that's probably why
she just flipped out this is my cooking
is Acutes Jobbik leg mommy in the
kitchen yeah
that's pretty on point I gotta say like
it like an old-school beautiful French
kitchen setup I mean that's a beautiful
kitchen I love this movie
you would never pour boiling anything
into another pot with boiling anything
because you'd burn yourself you know
like and you typically would not hold
the pan handle without a towel you know
on your hand because you'd most likely
burn yourself specifically if you're
dealing with copper pots that gets super
hot and then you also wouldn't stack
your pots on top of each other on the
station because you'd get screamed at
like she's about to do right now keep
your station clear or I won't get you
when your stations a mess everything
becomes a mess it's like you know like
they say the age-old saying like you
walk into a restaurant and if the
bathroom is a mess the bathrooms like
dirty you can only imagine what the
kitchen is like it's the same thing with
a cook if a cook stations all messed up
and this looks like there's no order you
just kind of know it's not it's not
happening it's not gonna work
yes please look like you threw up on
them keep your hands and arms in close
to the body like this see I think that
that's pretty much saying like you want
to keep everything tight clean efficient
you don't want your elbows sitting on
your station so you get them all dirty
like she was talking about before if you
don't want to be dirty you gotta be
organized you know and that's what she's
trying to do that's what every in fact
that's with all these clips it's all
about trying to be organized I gotta say
that like actually now like looking at
this cartoon they did an incredible job
of really making a kitchen feel like a
kitchen I mean even to the dish station
so that's the dish machine right there
like it's perfect the whole entire setup
and the line there and the dish that's
called the dish pit it could not be more
accurate remember what I said about
having different bowls for Muzo applause
so like you know they're not peeling
their potatoes on to their cutting board
they're peeling the potatoes into those
goals so it's nice and neat and clean
they have their peeled potatoes in that
container they have their unfilled
potatoes in the other container they're
peeling into the bowl it's pretty on
point guys thanks so much for watching
me break down these awesome classic
cooking clips power